la parole est à madame véronique
louwagie
merci monsieur le président de
l'association
l'assemblée nationale a adopté
définitivement hier le dernier projet de
loi de finance de la législature qui
constituera votre héritage et finalement
également un véritable passif pour vos
successeurs
je ne soulignerai ici que trois points
le matraquage fiscal d'abord votre
majorité n'aura eu de cesse de recourir
au bricolage fiscal qui s'est muée bien
souvent au matraquage fiscal pour des
franges entières de contribuables certes
vous avez décidé d'appliquer en janvier
une baisse d'impôt sur le revenu de 20%
mais ce cadeau ce cadeau du père noël
hollande ne sera octroyée qu'à un nombre
très limité de contribuables
il faut en parallèle rappelé depuis 2012
la pente ascendante de la courbe de
l'impôt sur le revenu avec une
progression ayant même atteint 14
milliards d'euros
ce sont finalement 31 milliards d'euros
de prélèvements en sus durant ce
quinquennat pris aux ménages la
sincérité des comptes ensuite vous en
atelier monsieur le premier ministre à
notre responsabilité est là également
notre responsabilité est de souligner
cette sincérité des comptes vos
prévisions de croissance
vos schémas budgétaire semble si peu
réaliste que même le haut conseil des
finances publiques et dans son avis du
14 novembre dernier extrêmement réservés
vous avez utilisé des tours de
passe-passe mettant en oeuvre une
véritable cavalerie budgétaire
un véritable hold up et le projet de
budget plus que soupçonner d'insincérité
la prochaine majorité héritera d'une
situation très dégradée à la fois en
2010 est également en 2018
car vos astuces budgétaire auront un
effet différé de l'ordre de 6 milliards
d'euros sur le seul sol de 2018
quant au prélèvement à la source vous
avez mis la charrue avant les boeufs car
une grande réforme fiscale aura été le
préalable
vous allez ainsi fragilisé les
entreprises inquiéter les contribuables
et surtout laisser à vos successeurs la
charge de gérer le service après vote de
cette réforme
une seule question quel bilan objectif
tirez vous de votre
le sapin ministre de l'économie et des
finances président madame véronique
louwagie
vous êtes une de celles dans
l'opposition qui suivait le plus
attentivement les débats parlementaires
les débats budgétaires et je veux rendre
hommage à votre assiduité
c'est la raison pour laquelle je vous
pensais capable d'avoir des arguments un
peu plus subtil que ce que vous venez de
prendre maintenant je vais répondre très
rapidement à deux ou trois de vos
remarques
première remarque puisque nous parlons
du budget pour 2010 est est ce que le
budget pour 2010 est permettra à la
france d'atteindre un déficit inférieur
à celui que vous nous avez laissé
[Musique]
vous-même avait le sourire aux lèvres
car vous savez très bien que le déficit
que vous avez laissé était supérieure à
5% renchérir les visites que jacques
doillon européenne elle-même reconnaît
comme étant celle que nous pouvons
atteindre sera inférieure à 3 pourtant
nous avons nous engager la diminution
des déficits de manière sérieuse de
manière pondérée de manière réaliste
tout en soutenant en particulier depuis
2014 la croissance qui est revenu etc a
permis de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
une capacité à faire face aux dépenses
supplémentaires
deuxième question celle de des impôts
madame l'hommage y vous savez très bien
où nous en étions au moment où là aussi
vous nous avez laissé des comptes en
main les impôts ne cessait d'augmenter
sur les ménages comme sur les
entreprises
l'un budget pour 2010 est j'ai acheté
une baisse des charges pesant sur les
autres
la dernière grande union allait baisser
et de baisses d'impôts pesant sur les
ménages
nous continuons à les baisser c'est la
réalité enfin il ya une grande réforme
celle sur le prélèvement à la source
comprend tout à fait qu'elle soit
débattue
c'est normal sont des sujets lourds
important et qui peuvent être
éventuellement difficile à mettre en
oeuvre
eh bien nous avons ensemble ici réussi à
élaborer une très belle réforme du
prélèvement à la source qui nous met
enfin enfin au même niveau qu'eux
les autres grands pays d'europe et du
monde le prélèvement à la source et de
la justice et de l'efficacité
si vous n'avez pas